what is up guys it is Jerry it's a
saturday morning and i'm here with some
impressions of stuff uh-huh i kinda late
showing last night of the new Seth
MacFarlane picture a million ways to die
in the west and I'm here to talk about
it now so um Seth MacFarlane's an
interesting dude to me as much as people
a bag on family guy you know oh it's not
as good as it used to be or you know
it's it's killing you know comedy uh
whenever I've got family guy on her
american dad on you know i'm always
enjoying myself you know i'm always
laughing even if it's it's something
stupid so you know i generally tend to
like Seth MacFarlane and I like that he
mixes base humor with intelligent humor
and Ed's in you know like music and
things that he really cares about you
know you can always feel his personality
and I appreciate that and his
directorial debut which was Ted I was
actually kind of impressed by I didn't
love that movie but I liked it and I
thought that he you know demonstrated
some some skill behind the camera and
it's always interesting to see somebody
transition out of animation into live
action you know Isabel very visual but
in a decidedly different way so I liked
what he did with Ted overall and I wish
I could say this movie builds upon that
but to me it's sort of backslides a bit
this movie you know takes place in the
Old West 1982 and it stars Seth
MacFarlane you know on-screen physically
this time um you know as this
down-on-his-luck sheep farmer he's not
very courageous you know he's not very
suited to the Old West and you know he's
he's suffering from heartbreak and a
number of other things I'm so you know
it's a familiar story but I think the
biggest thing for me about this movie is
that it's just really uneven first and
foremost you know I'll just get it out a
little way now is it funny yeah I left a
lot like I'm not gonna pretend I didn't
laugh a lot sometimes I was laughing
despite how obvious and stupid some of
the jokes were and sometimes I was
genuinely really enjoying the comedy so
you know even if you're not fully can
vinced by whatever joke there are so
many of them that you're gonna laugh at
something you know it's certainly
enjoyable and if you're just there to
have a good time with your buddies I'm
sure it'll be enjoyable I really think
this movie could have benefited from
tighter editing I mean this is watching
this in the theater it felt to me like I
was watching the you know extended
unrated edition on DVD you know cuz just
things go on and there are certain jokes
like okay I I get it it's a two hour
comedy so it's it's certainly lengthy
and after a while you do feel it start
to drag and the other thing too is that
this movie has this unique problem in
the sense that whenever Seth MacFarlane
is not on screen or in effect whenever
Seth MacFarlane basically gets to focus
on and direct the other actors the movie
feels like an actual movie and whenever
Seth MacFarlane is on screen it feels
sort of like a sketch show the moments
where sudden McFarland on screen or a
lot tighter are a lot more cinematic so
I think the challenge this time for him
was juggling being co-writer and
director and star with something like
Ted you know as I I just get the sense
that he was able to benefit from being
able to focus solely on directing a
movie and then acting where is in this
movie he definitely has to do a lot of
both and the thing is I don't think Seth
MacFarlane is a bad actor by any stretch
and I think he's very funny and again
you know I've really liked some of his
voice work in films like Ted N and
hellboy two I loved him is in hellboy
two so ultimately I think this film it
as much as I like him it always bogs
down whenever he's given a lot of screen
time you know to do his thing and
there's not a whole lot of
editing there you know it sort of seems
like they threw every joke at us and
whatever's funny is funny and whatever
is not snot you know he's got a lot of
great people around he's got you know
Neil Patrick Harris and Giovanni Ribisi
a man deciphered and charlize theron and
Liam Neeson um all of whom bring their
a-game and and Sarah Silverman in one of
the things I've liked her more in lately
and so it's it gets to be a little
strange because again I think such
MacFarlane can act but he's acting in a
different movie than the rest of his
cast a lot of the time it felt like
please forgive me because I know I'm
overanalyzing this but um this movie
seems to have sort of an intrinsic
difficulty for me anyway with comedy
generally because there are a lot of
ways to approach comedy you know if you
take something like Ted Ted takes a
ridiculous concept and it plays it
strained it plays with a straight face
you know Mark Wahlberg's character
that's just the reality of his world he
lives with his best friend who just so
happens to be a teddy bear and that
movie plays that as the reality and we
all know that that's ridiculous and part
of the humor comes from there but the
movie doesn't stop to be like we get
that it's ridiculous though and this
movie sort of doesn't know with her to
do that or not I feel like because the
supporting cast seems to all be you know
playing their role strand taking them
seriously it's not as though they think
they're doing Shakespeare but they're
all committed to their characters and so
part of the comedy comes from you know
eccentric characters and the part of the
comedy comes from just telling jokes so
you get half people who are really
committed to just being these wacky
people and accepting that reality and
then half people who seem to believe
what they're doing is funny and jokey
and and delivering it that way so it's
kind of like a guy trying to tell you a
joke and then cracking our pathway
through and then try to pull a straight
face back together before the
slime you know it's like comedies like
this seemed to work best when the actors
are playing the characters as though
there are actual people regardless of
how ridiculous they are and that only
happens like part of the time here and
you know I'm not gonna lie there there
is some humor in here that just isn't my
kind of humor so I'm not about to hold
that against the movie so much there
there are certain jokes i still think
could have been cut down despite that
but you know so mcfarland always has a
mix in his comedies of things that
appeal to me and and some things that
don't so that's that's fair enough it
may just be me a lot of the comedy and
this movie rests on anachronism so you
know people saying things that you never
would have said in the Old West because
they're modern and they incorporate
history that that people wouldn't have
known about yet or you know science that
we wouldn't have known about yet so some
of that stuff is funny and some of it
just doesn't really appeal to my taste
personally so that's not a criticism one
way or the other but just you know
depending on your taste and comedy I
guess he's got that lot but family guy's
style down better and better for live
action because there is a lot of that
cut away stuff and a lot of that really
physical comedy and there are some
really rewarding Easter eggs in there so
it's it's it's alright it doesn't all
feel like a complete whole to me but um
I appreciate that you know there's a lot
of sweeping visuals which really cool
the scores is really good because it
harks back to all those old western
movies and there were some really
amusing bits and there are some great
cameos and I really wish the trailers
you know I've seen a lot of trailers for
this movie just at the cinema and on TV
they give away a lot of the slapstick
you know punchlines and they give away a
few of the really good cameos and that's
a bummer because there are a lot of
really fun cameos and they're not all
give it away and there's a lot of
slapstick but you know it's once you've
seen a moment like that it's you know
it's not as funny it's like finding your
Christmas presents early and then
opening them you know it's like you're
not gonna be surprised anymore so um
that's more on the ad campaign the movie
because all those moments are really
funny and I wish I could have seen them
for the first time or most of them for
the first time you
the movie itself um but it's an
enjoyable time you know you go to a
matinee or or you rent it with your
friends or something like that um it's a
good time I think it's not blazing
saddles by any stretch of the
imagination but um it's an alright movie
kind of sinks under the weight of not
knowing when to pick it up and move
along I think but it certainly got a
good heart you know it's good natured
it's hearts in the right place it really
wants to make you laugh you can tell
there you know it just has you know this
gleeful aura but um it's you know it's
it's certainly worth checking out if you
want to go and have a silly laugh you
know um it's worth checking out I'm
hoping that his you know next film is a
little more solid and a little more
refined than this but again for what it
is and especially if you're interested
in it you'll probably have a good time
as a film you know if I you have to
review it like a film there are a lot of
problems to keep it from being great but
it's a good time so um yeah that's sort
of my two cents on this I certainly left
I will give it that um so yeah Seth
MacFarlane what do you guys think what's
your favorite of his works what would
you like to see him do in the future um
you know it's what's dish see ya until
next time I am Jerry a million ways to
die in the west is the film and cheers
you